hey guys welcome back to visual effects
artist reacts oh my goodness if you have
seen that DND movie you know there's
some incredible shots in it that oh here
we go here we go
here we go how would you part the ocean
if you didn't have any computers and
you're making a movie in 1956 oh this is
kind of cool whoa weird what also in the
new Thor movie they shot this entire
action sequence at almost 600 frames per
second this is really cool technology
but
I'll be honest I can't see it in the
final product well then good that's kind
of the point right we got a real spicy
episode today we're gonna Jump Right In
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
so you've seen the new Dungeons and
Dragons right yeah I've yet to see it
it's really good I haven't seen yet
either you know like we've been making
DND shows you know we play it a lot so
you know there's certain expectations
you have going into it but it's just a
great movie and it's like it feels as
fun as playing the game it's like the
same Vibe they really nailed it and it
looks incredible and there's tons and
tons and tons of crazy VFX in this a
wild shape is Among Us
is she passing her perception check yep
she did yep
she caught the flight so this is the
Druid character it's pretty sweet oh my
God I'm getting Bollywood Vibes now yep
[Laughter]
from a fly to a rat
[Music]
oh that's really cool that's a great
idea actually yeah wow
d d game idea see this is what I'm
saying this movie is like so dope
[Laughter]
yeah it's pretty sweet also this hasn't
cut yet this is all still one take yeah
this is pretty cool isn't it weird that
we've arrived in an era of filmmaking
where we have wonders which aren't about
not having any Cuts it's not about like
oh I got a long take it's more about
this real time just playing out of a
scene yeah without edits in it
oh there's lots of polymorphs going on
interesting to go to the shadow to like
not have to deal with the morph from the
cat to the human being yeah it's like
let's just paint over here show the
reaction
short rest after that one wait that was
like yeah
foreign
so like obviously the scene has a ton of
CG but I think there's like two parts in
it that I think are kind of clever with
kind of blending the two I think the
first one is is that moment where it's
the mouse sneaking into the suit of
armor so this is full CG here obviously
yeah and that's full CG and then I think
there's a basically right as they get to
the foot of that that's where it
transitions into that practical shot so
if you're shooting this do you have her
in the suit of armor I would and then
painter out basically yeah in the way
her face kind of grows into the helmet
implies that that's just a kind of a 2d
composite effect that was what I was
thinking her face is probably there the
whole time and they just like painted
out the face replaced it with the inside
of the helmet and then just like took a
frame of that face and just like shrunk
it down and you can kind of see it track
a little bit weirdly in there like right
there's a little Bobble yeah like it's
super minor yeah so if she's actually in
there walking whatnot but then oh now
her face is gone well it's also
transitioning back to the full CG suit
in the middle of that run which is
really well done like you don't notice
it at all the transition point is
definitely when the helmet gets hit it's
that classic you know match cut
situation where you have that violent
motion that allows you to transfer it to
the suit also that shoulder plate hits
the ground and kind of like moves a
little weird yeah it's like it falls
down and then they like animate it off
to the right it's one of those things in
the directions like I want this to go
over here it's like sir the physics
don't work that way it's like screw
physics I'm the director I am a God and
like that's my favorite stuff anyways is
when it is feeling like a magic trick
and that sequence does that because yeah
you're kind of going okay well hold on
how did we get from A to B like I'm
seeing something real like how did you
pull that off and yeah it's fun clever
uh So speaking about this is also
another fun topic we've covered this
next scene here in a variety of
different ways it's one of my personal
favorites get ready
that oh here we go here we go
wait is that Bradley Cooper yeah
so what have you been up to there's a
little bit of uncanny valleyness going
on here I have a feeling that most of
this stuff is not actually forced
perspective I think they actually just
composited it looks good to me yeah very
well what is cons because I think he's
sitting on a big chair I don't think so
I think he's sitting on a completely
different chair that is not in the shot
I think the actual chair we're looking
at is actually on the set with Michelle
Rodriguez there look at the size of the
wood grain look at Michelle Rodriguez's
chair look at the wood grain on that
chair see how it's very big and vague
and flat and low contrast I know look at
Bradley Cooper's chair see look at look
at the detail on that no that's a real
chair oh
oh Gwen this is hoga wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa that that's the shot that we can
tell so look at how her arm is over the
chair yeah that's a big chair they're
copping her arm over the chair are they
I
she's a normal sized woman that's a real
chair and look at her little Shadow from
her wrist touching the chair no comp
artist would ever just let's see oh my
God you're right I didn't catch them so
those little details like no compart
just like yes let me hop in the tiny
little hair from the corner of her wrist
as a shadow maybe there is some insane
genius out there who put the little
shadow on the chair but I just feel like
if you were to shoot this scene it would
be doing a disservice not to make a big
chair and just have him interact with a
big chair this is why I want to watch it
though it's a perfect speculation scene
because there's moments where it looks
Flawless you know yeah like this over
the shoulder shot and it really just
comes down to like what do you think
they did to achieve it don't we have the
visual effects supervisor from this
movie lined up to join us soon yes let's
get someone from ilm to come here
foreign subscribe if you don't want to
miss the follow-up episode where you
actually get the answer to our questions
we're going to take a real quick break
here to talk about vessi today's sponsor
a shoe that I wear
wears these shoes check out Chase here
he edits all these react episodes Chase
so tell me about Messi why do you like
bestie they just slide right on and off
look at this
this has laces
what do you love about besties uh oh hey
what's up how you doing for me honestly
it's the waterproof fun fact these shoes
are breathable so your feet don't get
wet even if they're sweaty they're bone
dry smell and honestly when you get them
dirty just hose them up I have about
four different pairs of essies so I
rotate dude I also have four do you
actually yeah and they're all
fashionable and cool
this is very difficult to do you're
wearing dusties right now look at this
everyday Classics what are these shoes
even made out of they're made of this
patented Diamond text material keeps
your feet warm in the winter and cool in
the summer Nick you're even wearing
vesties right now I am wearing besties
storm burst oh yeah man these are
slip-on hiking boots I guess I'm gonna
have to have five pairs of vessels
because I need to buy this pair of shoes
right now so they're doing a Memorial
Day sale right now where you can get up
to 30 off but even if you miss out on
that it's okay because you can always
use our code court or crew to get 15 off
any new Vesti they're super comfy all
you gotta do is go to the link in the
description or just you know vesti.com
quarter crew but in the meantime I'm
gonna go see what kind of stunts Adam
Sandler can do in the water is see a
Dawson
I got a VFX guessing time for you guys
oh yeah I know we kind of said it was
DND but this is for real because I
actually know the answer oh wait I might
know the answer to this too this was a
recommended sequence for us to look at
from one of the previous reactions
somebody left a comment so thanks for
leaving me a comment love it when you
guys leave comments let's check it out
this is just this is funny
[Music]
it was great that's so well done that's
really well done all right this came out
in 2008. how do you think they did this
the
some sort of like robot arm attached off
to the side of a boat and they're
actually like gliding through the water
because it looks like from chest up he's
definitely real and definitely diving
through the water obviously there's like
a camera boat yeah we see the wake of
some sort of boat off to the right of
France why not just uh there's another
boat with the crane arm that's dangling
him you know it's basically wire work
it's got to be with some paint out but
how are they doing it so that he's like
so cleanly going through the water and
out in these very natural arcs oh let go
pull it's a thing you have to you know
work on in time and practice a little
bit you guys have a bunch of great
guesses and Sam was the closest actually
what they did is they took a boat they
built a truss system on it and then
wires came down and Adam Sandler's being
lifted in and out of the water while he
does the butterfly is basically a 100
practical shot with just the wires and
maybe some trust being removed from
Shots once in a while what blows my mind
about that is that he's able to actually
go through that swimming motion yeah and
that's actually Adam Sandler yeah in
that shot there so it's not like it's a
stunt double maybe for some of the wide
shots but like at least for these
close-up ones that's definitely him
doing the stuff yeah that's good acting
like to be doing that much physicality
you're going probably 20 miles an hour
15 miles an hour in that water like
that's a lot of water hitting you and
still like getting the look up the
connection with your eyes the big
breaths it looks like you're coming
after him like that's tough but I'd
assume they probably have a wire on his
ankles for some of those custom shots to
get his legs up and of course you know
he's probably pinned at the hips
unfortunately I don't know behind the
scenes on this are almost impossible to
find and like Google's gotten so useless
these days that I can't find it anymore
I have a request to anyone who is going
to interview Adam Sandler in the future
please ask him about how they did this
shot
oh God
so next up we're looking at Thor love
and thunder but this sequence in
particular was pretty sweet
I don't want to call it a gimmick but
the whole idea here is that they're on a
very tiny Moon and it's rotating and so
the star that's lighting the place is
rotating around the planet and that's
changing the Shadows on all of these
actors wait a minute I never saw this
movie but I was reading I do my reading
from time to time did they use some
crazy like strobe stuff to film this yes
they did Sam so like and that's why I
want to talk about this
you've got this very complicated
choreography between like three or four
different actors you know they're moving
around the cameras cutting back and
forth between these people but if you
have a light that is moving in the shot
that lighting is now baked into your
footage and you can quickly run into
continuity problems so basically trying
to figure out how can we film something
but then change the lighting later to a
different angles exactly and so a
company called satellite Labs developed
a system called plate light they filmed
on a phantom Onyx camera and they shot
everything at 576 frames per second
movies are played back at 24 frames per
second so at 576 frames per second
you're recording every frame has 24
frames that you can pick and choose from
and they have six different lights
circling the entire set and each light
strobes in sync with the footage that's
being recorded and on set it's
flickering so fast you can't even see it
so it just looks like all the lights are
just on all the time so for every single
little frame of footage at 24fps they
can pick and choose where the lights
came from or combine them or transfer
between them and that gave them so much
flexibility for choosing where the
lights were coming from in post this is
really cool and really cool technology
but I'll be honest I can't see it in the
final product well you're not that's
well then good that's kind of the point
right the light doesn't seem to move
because I'm feeling that too where I
want to see more of the dynamic lighting
shifts happen I agree with you and who
knows why they didn't do that maybe the
transitioning didn't work quite as well
for some of the shots maybe it was too
distracting I think they just like their
Edge lights too much you know they're
going to develop this incredible rig for
doing crazy lighting I would love to see
it featured I'd love to see the light
truly circling around the characters but
it's so subtle it's like super super
impressive stuff to orchestrate and set
this whole rig up but you know it
definitely feels like one of those
things where it's definitely more on the
filmmaker side of things like making
their lives easier versus making an
image that's a little more exciting well
the thing that they were trying to fight
against is having the Bland sort of look
that you typically see in a lot of
superhero movies these days because you
know so much of this stuff is going to
be changed after the fact and they don't
want to have any of this baked in and if
let's say okay they need to re-light
Chris Hemsworth they just they have to
relight them in a traditional workflow
you would have to literally create a
digital twin of him and track it to the
actual actor so that then you can add a
CG light onto the digi double that then
you put on top of the footage and that
takes a lot of time and it's very
expensive to do and it's hard and it
doesn't always work that well I totally
get that but but but but here's the
crazy thing all the technology and all
the work to get let them do lighting
from different angles in this film in
the years since this film has been made
which is what like two years three years
there's now automatic AI generated
normal maps in DaVinci Resolve where you
can just re-light your characters yeah
and it's really easy to do it looks like
you literally make a node a re-light
node and then you put these little CG
lights in your scene and it's not
Flawless but it's a lot better and a lot
faster than doing it all by hand and
it's just interesting to see like how
much work had to go into getting the
ability to do that here and in just this
short span of time it is literally a
node in a free software program
[Laughter]
I don't think the normal map approach is
that good at doing behind the eyes
you're right it's not there is one shot
I want to look at real quick though see
that light going up on his face there
yeah from the hammer the light is very
much so coming from the left and they're
able to synchronize it between the two
but then as the light of the hammer is
coming up it's Illuminating his face
realistically and his whole chest
realistically because they actually got
that light and they're able to extract
that just for that little bit of time
now like you're saying with the AI
relighting stuff in DaVinci now it can
do that but can it do it at the level of
quality that Blockbuster films hold
themselves to these days that's a good
question and this is also like I think
the first feature film that they use
this Tech on and you know this is a
Marvel movie it's a very very large ship
with a lot of chefs in the kitchen you
know it's like who knows how much of the
original vision for using this system
really ended up being able to be used at
the end of the day I'm glad they're
starting down this path of like synced
up lights because I could see it having
a ton of power in the future and opening
a bunch of like creative possibilities
yeah also
also it's on the sequence oh really yeah
but because he's under NDA he couldn't
talk about it
but I'm not under NDA
all right I love old effects back before
computers existed it's like when you see
a magician do a trick in front of you
live and there's nothing between you and
them but the air and the photons it's
one of the most mind-blowing things yes
that's how I feel about old films so
let's take a look at some very high
effort effects from 1956.
[Music]
all right so right off the bat what is
that background yeah it's very spooky
stormy is that is that a rip projection
background I think that's very projected
okay because it's like there's
definitely no matting look at this
oh that's fun
oh this is kind of cool whoa weird what
now is that just a bunch of like smoke
and a very powerful vacuum behind a
bunch of water and a pool oh it looked
like that water was going backwards this
is cool yep definitely backwards Rushing
Water oh wow whoa whoa pretty damn
impressive for 1956. how do you guys
think they got those water elements on
the side no you were looking at there is
that a Jacuzzi it's like a Jacuzzi yeah
yeah but this one looks weird yeah how
do you think they got that element there
because one thing oh yeah The Confident
element was like well yeah but they had
to get that element
let's go to a waterfall and film it
they're actually they're basically
custom-made waterfalls so what they
basically have is the largest wing on
the Slick surface and it's hitting the
actual tank of water causing it to
bubble and froth and it's flowing off
again it's almost got like a laminar
flow to it and that's helping it get
underneath the water and causing that
turbulence and that sort of weird
unnatural way yeah it's not like they
just pointed a camera on a hot tub yep
and then it still has a waterfall Edge
to it beyond that so it bubbles up and
then flows again which gives you this
weird effect like the water coming
sideways and then rising up out of the
way
this is how they opened it and they
played this backwards and that was the
Feathering
super cool hell yeah that's great there
is still compositing happening and
somebody taking like okay I got water
element one Water Element two background
element put them all together and have
animators paint the transitions like the
actual effects part is basic these days
right it's it's a couple masks in like
three or four elements yeah but you have
to get the elements and that's not basic
at all you have to film the actual water
doing these actual things you have to
film the crowds you have to film The
Incredible like value that they walk
through this is back in the day when
like filming the stuff is hard now we
can generate those elements you know
versus filming the elements oh and don't
forget
it doesn't just stay open
oh man those people they're getting
dumped Moses man yeah wait is that blue
screen behind the water the Big Splash
I'm looking at Blue coloring through the
water it does look like blue screen
doesn't it yeah I think that's blue
screen this might be blue screen and
that's just for like the rock element
there in the front and what looks like a
separate element of a whole bunch of
people behind them and then a far
element which is probably just like a
matte painting yeah dang Ten
Commandments back when they cast a bunch
of white actors to play Egyptians
I guess not much has changed still
dealing with that problem thanks for
watching Everybody if you enjoy these
episodes we have extended ones on
Corridor digital.com and sad free and
you can go on your TV we have TV apps
now this is going to be long and
extend too so sign up you get a free
trial